la hacienda nápoles la tierra soñada del
narcotraficante colombiano más famoso
dos mil hectáreas de pastos bosques y
lagos artificiales a los que dio forma
pablo escobar un pequeño paraíso para
estos hipopótamos la mayor manada
salvaje que vive fuera de áfrica de
donde son originarios los hipopótamos de
escobar son las estrellas del parque
temático creada la propiedad incautada
por el estado tras la muerte del
narcotraficante
mirad eso se llama hipopótamo
son los descendientes de cuatro
ejemplares traídos clandestinamente en
la década de 1980 para el zoológico
privado de escobar se reprodujeron y
ahora son más de 100 no están bajo
condiciones de 3 no tienen depredadores
el clima de colombia les favorece
muchísimo
entonces eso ha hecho que se dispare la
población
vale está en el parque viven tres de
estos animales incluida a vanessa que
fue abandonada de bebé por la manada
como se crió desde pequeña con nosotros
llega
permite que nosotros tengamos ese
acercamiento con un hipopótamo de vida
libre sería imposible
los demás hipopótamos viven en libertad
a medida que se multiplican formas
nuevos grupos que salen a colonizar el
territorio se encuentran a más de 150
kilómetros de la hacienda nápoles
ok y por supuesto en desire en esta zona
todavía salvaje la observación de
hipopótamos al atardecer es una de las
actividades propuestas a los visitantes
hay que tomar precauciones como mantener
distancia son animales de dos toneladas
y media tres en su adultez nadan mucho
más rápido que nosotros corren más de 40
kilómetros en tierra y pues no no no
queremos poner en riesgo la seguridad de
nadie porque pues es una experiencia los
hipopótamos atraen a los turistas como a
estos estadounidenses pero su impacto
sobre el ecosistema y la vida local es
grave es un arma de doble filo para
nosotros los operadores del turismo
naturaleza queremos mostrarlos pero nos
preocupa muchísimo su presencia
ok
a menudo invisibles impredecibles estos
gigantes son un peligro para los
habitantes de la región no muy lejos del
recorrido realizado por camilo el guía
un campesino fue atacado y gravemente
herido
yo estaba mirando una compañero mío que
con un compadre
cuando el animal me atacó fue hace un
año luis enrique era jornalero en una
granja junto al río como operador
turístico que no tengo mucha curiosidad
el animal en el momento del ataque
como yo y voy aquí para allá y el animal
me colgó por detrás
me cogió por la espalda y por la espalda
que el mejor huyen de la mitad cuando
sentimos cuando lo único que sentí yo
cuando lo guardo atrás ya no fue lo
único que yo sentí no me toques aquí
perdí la
y la pierna y la espalda
ahora está discapacitado y no tiene
recursos
este es el peor accidente registrado en
la región pero no es el único porque
cuando viaja parando en el terreno 11
pases de voltear la canoa
llena de gente
como
con animales además de ruiz
según algunas estimaciones en 2050 los
hipopótamos colombianos podrían llegar a
ser miles a veces se les puede ver en
los pueblos
[Música]
ella mascota
en gran número estos mega herbívoros
amenazan las especies locales devoran
las riberas de los ríos e incluso son
capaces de desviar su curso el futuro de
los hipopótamos de escobar es un
rompecabezas para los científicos
normalmente están con las orillas
entonces vamos a estar muy atento como
para arrancar a correr porque ellos a
veces salen a atacar listo
david echeverry es un biólogo que
trabaja en la agencia regional encargado
de la flora y fauna
este es un juvenil lleva varios años
trabajando para contener la
proliferación de los hipopótamos este
corral de tubos metálicos fue instalado
para capturarlos y realizar operaciones
de esterilización
especialmente delicadas
todo con los hipopótamos es complejo es
costoso es demorado y fuera de eso es
muy peligroso trasladar este escenario a
la vida silvestre es una tarea casi que
imposible en total 35 hipopótamos entre
más de 80 han sido esterilizados pero la
tarea apenas comienza no hay una
solución definitiva por el riesgo
portamos voy a decir que lo vamos a
matar todos eso no es posible es decir
que lo vamos a capturar todos tampoco
algunos podrían ser adoptados por
instituciones especializadas david hace
un llamado a los zoológicos de todo el
mundo
que nos contacte a nosotros los
invitamos como tal no tienen precios a
lo que necesitamos que nos ayuden es en
la logística para llevárselos
casi 30 años después de su muerte el
legado de pablo escobar sigue afectando
a colombia